>>John Panzer:
Okay, hi everybody, uh, I'm John Panzer.
>>Joseph Smarr:
And I'm Joseph Smarr.
>>John Panzer:
And we're here to talk to you today about
bridging the island and providing fluid social
experiences across the entire social web.
Alright? [pause] We'll be talking about that
guy a little later. So, uh, first before we
get started, I just want to let you know the
Wave URL for this session is this bit.ly link.
Um, you can copy it down and please use that
as the back channel and chat about us as much
as you want, and we'll also put additional
information and links and resources up there.
Um, now first I want to ask a question. How
many people here came to and listened to Chris
Messina's talk this morning. Okay, a fair
number of people, some people didn't, um,
but just so you know we are going to be recapping
a little bit of his story. Because it's the
same story, the story of the social web, um,
and so the first thing I'm going to do before
we go into the technical details is to tell
you guys a story.
So, once upon a time...there was a girl named
"Kate" and there was a guy named "Jack." And
Kate and Jack, well, turns out that they lived
on two separate islands. They, they didn't
know each other, they never saw each other.
But just by coincidence, one day they both
decided to go on vacation. And they ended
up on the same island. Now, this was an amazing
coincidence that they came to the same island,
they met, and as fate would have it, you know,
they fell in love. So yay! Yay for Kate and
Jack. Alright. This is a good story right?
Boy meets girl? Okay, good. Now that's great,
but there's a problem. When Kate and Jack
left their original home islands, they left
their friends and family behind on their old
islands, and they wanted to stay in touch,
but it's very hard to do that on these islands.
As it turns out, it's really hard to visit
other islands. When people try, they get stopped.
The, [laughs] the border guards won't let
them. Before they'll let you visit another
island, you have to go and fill out forms.
Lots of forms. Lots and lots of forms. A different
form for every new island. So users are very
unhappy about this. Some big islands saw a
problem with this and they got together and
two of them got together, sometimes three
of them, and they said they were going to
solve it for their users and they started
letting their islanders visit each other without
the forms. They would honor each other's forms.
Well that's great for the big islands, but
it left a lot of people out in the cold. It's
not so great for all the little islands, and
there's a lot of people on these little islands.
So people still had to fill out a lot of forms.
So um, that didn't work for everybody. So
what happened was, some uh, young islanders,
we technically call them geeks, got together
and they decided that we're going to come
up with a solution for this that will work
for all the islands and for everybody, all
the time. And so they made up some uh, they
came up with a solution that would let the
islanders travel around and visit the other
islands without having to go and fill out
all of these darn forms. So, this is a big
problem for the islanders and it's also a
big problem for us today here on the social
web. So, now I'm going to hand things over
to Joseph to talk a bit more about our problems
on the social web and perhaps even a few solutions.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Thanks John. So, you know, we've got our own
sort of immigration problem on the social
web today. If you are like me, you still basically
have separate accounts, profiles, etcetera
on pretty much every website you go to. And
you know sometimes we just sort of take for
granted this is the way things are, but it
actually leads to a lot of problems. Clearly,
most obvious, there's, there's friction every
time you want to try a new service, because
you have to fill out yet another form, you
have to remember your password. And what happens
as a result is that the net effect that there's
a lot of people who haven't filled out their
profiles very well. A lot of very sparsely
populated profiles, a lot of profiles out
of date, uh, personal example, I was at Plaxo
until recently, I, I joined Google in January,
but there's lots of profiles that still say
I work at Plaxo because it was just too hard
to go and change each one of them one by one.
It also leads to poor security because if
you are like me you don't actually use a separate
password for every single website you use,
you tend to use the same one over and over
again.
>>John Panzer:
--You don't?!
>>Joseph Smarr:
Um, I, I, I must confess. Now what's humorous
to me is not only is this problematic from
a security perspective, it's still the case
that one of the biggest complaints that any
website has is lost password problems from
their users. Because it's just too much hassle
to remember which user name or email address
that I used, or was it my one password or
second password and this obviously is a problem
as well. And then perhaps more subtly but
actually more importantly, I think that when
these islands are all fragmented by default,
uh, interop is hard. You know, you don't know
who else the person is, you don't have any
of their data, and so you just tend not to
get as much rich interaction between the sites
that people use. And when you do get interaction,
it tends to be biased towards just picking
a few big services and working with them because
you really don't know which services the user
is on, and each integration is separate and
so you just don't have the ability to easily
let users come and use the tools and services
their comfortable with, and have it all just
work. In summary, this is bad for developers
and bad for users. And, well, thank you for
these automated transitions, but we have good
news! [laughs] Let's do that one again, that's
too good. It's bad for users, it's bad for
developers. But there's got to be a better
way, and there is!
[laughter]
Heh? Because of course, there are now a bunch
of technologies being developed that allow
you to sign up for new services using the
accounts you've already got. And if you think
about it, there's actually sort of two related
problems tied up in here. One is, who is this
person? If I can show you my identity from
an existing service, I don't have to have
that separate user name and password for you
to know who I am. And of course lots of services
I not only have an account, I have useful
data there, and if I can authorize you access
to have some of my data, without having to
give away my password and everything that
comes with it, then I'm much more likely to
want to participate. And there are increasingly
open standards that are actually behind a
lot of these. So most big services today,
have some service now, this wasn't true even
a year or two ago, I've been speaking at I/O
for a while, and it's amazing how much better
the situation gets each year. So, almost all
of the big providers now support OpenID and
OAuth. Including Google, and Yahoo! and Facebook,
and LinkedIn, and Twitter, and on and on and
on. So you not only have a chance to use a
lot of these big services to help the user
come to your site faster, you aren't having
to build it from scratch as much every time
you want to work with a different provider.
And of course that allows you to work with
smaller providers that you might not have
heard of but that speak the same standards.
Now uh, one of the things that people mention
a lot is okay, so how am I supposed to tell
the user, ask the user which services they
use because there's lots of different services
out there, there's new services changing all
the time? So, one of the things we've been
working on is better ways to have that communication
about here are the tools I already use so
that you can offer me a more personalized
experience. And there are actually a bunch
of different ways. I don't think it's that
bad to what a lot of sites do now is they'll
have buttons to for a lot of the popular services.
You'll see a sign up with your Google account,
or sign up with your Facebook account or sign
up with your Twitter account. And I think
that's reasonable as long as it's not the
only way people can provide their own information.
You want to still let the smaller guys come
in and play too because today's small guys
are going to be tomorrow's big guys. In many
cases though, you actually have some clues.
So for example, if you are inviting people
to join your service, you're sending invites
to your friends, you can look at their email
address, and if it's a Gmail email address,
well maybe you should offer them a Google
onboarding experience, right? And so forth.
And often times, you know, if you are sharing
content out into say Twitter of Facebook or
Buzz, and you are getting clicks, you can
look at the referrer's of the links and you
can say, "Oh the person is coming from Facebook
so maybe I should offer them a Facebook onboarding."
And again that sort of breaks that logjam
of, of not having a clue of which services
the person's on. There are even better ways
that are coming out now. There's a technology
called webfinger I'll show you a little about.
Where, I, you can basically look up a person
by their email address or their account ID,
and the service will actually list, here are
the services I'm on, or here is some information
about me. So if you, you know, it's very common
for users to give their email address when
they are trying out new services, and now
you can look that up and figure out more about
them. And there's also a technology that we've
been working on with partners called XAuth,
where the actual browser can hold some basic
information about what services you use, and
as you go around to those services, you can,
they can push that information to XAuth. Not
giving your private data without your permission,
but a little hint, like, hey someone on this
computer is using Google, maybe you want to
show the Google thing, or maybe on a smaller
services and other sites can query that and
see. So there's sort of a whole set of different
technologies you can use to figure out how
to offer the user a better experience.
Okay, let me show you a little demo here.
Wifi gods...hopefully will be cooperative.
Now where's my...where's my other window for
Chrome.
[pause]
Where's my cursor either.
[sings] do do doo doo.
This one right? You can see it right? Okay
there, the magic of mirror displays. So here's
a good example. My friend Hong uses Gmail
and I've invited him to join Plaxo. Some of
you may have seen this demo before, but it's
just that good. Um, when he clicks on this
invite link like he's done a million times,
Plaxo recognizes he's coming in from a Gmail
address and so rather showing yet another
one of those immigration forms, he says, "Hey,
why not get started quickly using your existing
Google account." And so this then is using
OpenID and OAuth and it says, "Hey Hong."
And of course you'll note he's already logged
in because of course he just came from Gmail.
It says, "Is it okay if Plaxo has your email
address and accesses to your address book
so you can get started quickly." And if Hong
likes this site he can try it. And rather
than having yet another form, I'm just instantly
put into the app, and I already have my information.
And crucially, I'm not having to fill out
a separate password so instead the first thing
I see on the site is let me answer that friend
request. And so I've just removed that friction.
And now even better, rather than asking me,
"Oh, which address book do you use, give me
your credentials, let me scrape it," the way
it is so often. They're able to just take
my address book directly using OAuth and then
the next thing I see is, "Oh, here are some
people you already know who are on Plaxo,
I can get started with them." So it's a very
seamless experience and it's better for users
because they don't have to start out from
scratch all the time and it's better for you
site developers because your able to um, very
quickly get the users up and running and get
a lot more valuable data. Uh, now I mentioned
XAuth which is a complimentary thing where
if the user didn't happen to come from Gmail,
they still might be able to tell you, "Hey
I'm on Google."
And here's a little demo that Meebo put together,
and here's a bunch of services and it's using
XAuth to figure out whether I’m signed in
or not. And so, in this case, I'm going to
go sign into Google. And it asks me to sign
in. So imagine this is me going to check my
Gmail or something, and then when I login,
it sets a little bit in XAuth that says this
person used Google, and now when I've come
back to Meebo, it can see that I'm signed
into Google. And what's cool is that if I
did that on these other sites, Meebo's not
going, having to go check every site one after
another, it just asks XAuth where is the person,
and you can see it. And if I can, here I can
actually pull up...XAuth.org. Whoa, the remote
type is surprisingly challenging...This is,
just as a developer you can go there and you
can see that on XAuth, think of it as just
sort of a glorified third party cookie, it's
actually using some cool HTML5 features called
HTML5 post message and local storage so none
of this is kept up in the clouds it's just
on your browser. Um, I can see that this Google
demo is being set as me being active and of
course as the user I can go in and change
that or even block it or disable XAuth entirely
if I'm not comfortable with it so it's just
a nice little way of helping mash those things
up together.
Alright, let's go back to our story. How are
our friends doing on the island? Let's talk
a little bit first about, just sort of mechanically
speaking how much you integrate this into
your site. So in both cases what you saw is
what we call doing the dance which is sending
the user over to the provider to get authorization
and then having them come back with the information.
Both OpenID and OAuth work the same way in
the sense that they send you over and when
they redirect over to your site, you have
some extra information on the URL that you
can use. And there's a hybrid of OpenID and
OAuth which I showed you which it works in
one step. And there's even a newer version
being worked on now called OpenID Connect
that builds this on top of OAuth 2.0 that
is even simpler for developers, so a lot of
great work happening in this space. You just
save the information you get back and in the
case of OpenID, it's the identifier of the
user, so maybe it's my Google ID and you can
just save that in your database and you can
actually create still a local account and
so if you think about the old way you create
user accounts, you can still create a simple
account but rather than having a password
for me you can just link to my Google ID.
And the way OpenID works is the only way I
can prove to you that I own that Google ID
is if I really came from Google, so that once
you see that, you can trust that it really
is me, and you can log me in. So it's equivalent
to a password in that sense. And for OAuth,
you can store a token and you can use that
to make API calls and so you can access my
address book. And what's cool is that since
you aren't taking passwords you can actually
store the token because they are safe and
I can always revoke them if I want to and
so rather than doing a onetime import for
your friends the way most services do, you
can actually be periodically checking, because
if your service is taking off, you know, a
month from now or three months from now, a
bunch of my friends are probably going to
be using and I'm probably going to want to
know about that and you are going to want
to tell me because it's going to make me come
back over and over again. And then with XAuth,
there's just a very simple little JavaScript
and you can go to XAuth.org and find out,
and we'll have a list of links at the end
of this talk with, with pointers and the slides
will be online so you don't have to copy this
down now, but there's one little simple JavaScript
call that says if you are a site and you want
other sites to have your little share button
or your little login button, that just says,
"Hey I’m alive, someone is here," and similarly
you can request and say which sites are the
user using and use that to personalize your
experience. So very simple kind of very little
things you can drop in and get going.
And once the islanders realize that they can
do this, they essentially had a passport system
for the islands, so no more forms on every
site, you already had your island identification
and you could just come present it on a new
island and everyone was very happy. Yay! Alright,
that brings us to Chapter II and I'll hand
it back to John for Chapter III.
So, chapter II is about staying connected.
Now Kate when she was back on her own island,
she was, you know just Kate, right? Everybody
just knew her. And Jack, when he was back
on his island, was just Jack but when they
went to a new island, things got a little
more complicated because now, how did their
friends call them or send them a message?
They couldn't just call Jack or Kate; they
had to figure out John or Kate at the new
island. So they needed some way of still being
able to find each other and stay in touch
even when they were all living on these different
islands. So our intrepid little web hackers
got together and said, "Gee what we really
need is some sort of a forwarding service
where people can move about the island the
way they want and still find a way to be contacted
when they're on their new island." And course
while this is a problem for our little islander
friends, it's also a problem here for us out
here on the social web. Because if you think
about it, we need forwarding addresses for
the social web as well. The fact that we have
these separate ids, user names, and friend
lists on every website means that when I come
to a website, it's pretty hard to figure out
which of my friends are already there. You
know, maybe they have a lookup by email address,
but increasingly I know people other than
by email address. Right? I might know you
on Twitter or on Facebook or on any other
service. And conversely, as a user, it's a
little hard for me to figure out how much
control I have over who can find me and by
what. Right? So sometimes you go to a new
website and you are surprised, how did this
person find me there because the fact that
this is not really well systematized sort
of means that it's sort of too hard when we
want to find people and it's too hard when
you don't want to be found. It also means
that the information shared in each of these
websites tends to stay within each of their
own websites. And if you're like me, the more
services you try to use, you sort of got separate
places you have to go, each one with their
own little news feed, each one with their
own social inbox, etcetera, and it's sort
of hard to get a sense overall of what people
are doing without having to live in all the
different place they are. This would be like
having to visit each island just to figure
out what was going on. And the messaging system
themselves are also fragmented. So, if I want
to comment on your story, or if I want to
just send you a message and share with you,
um, it's hard to do that if I'm on one service
and you’re on another service, right? And
if you think about it again, sort of nobody's
really winning here, there's just sort of
fragmentation because the whole social web
is still in quite a primitive state. So, what’s
the conclusion here? I can think you can say
it with me now, it's bad for users, it's bad
for developers and it makes little storm clouds
on the island. We've got to be able to better
than that right?
Well, once again, I've got good news for you!
And that is there's now technology that helps
you actually link the profiles that you use
together, and that lets you then figure out
how to be found and bring your friends with
you when you check out new websites. So, the
first thing is to figure out how should somebody
find me when I go to a new website? And of
course conversely how should I find other
people. And there are a few different things
you can do. So, if I have different profiles
all around the web, I can actually, and obviously
if I was logged in with OpenID, that's one
way of linking profiles, but I can also just
put little links on my existing profiles to
the other sites I use. And of course you don't
have to link together all of your profiles,
if you want to keep your work and your personal
separate or things like that, you can certainly
keep those separate, but if I want to put
a few things together and say, you know, me
on Twitter and me on Facebook, and me on Google
is really the same person, I can just put
these little hyperlinks between the sites
and there's a little microformat where you
just put rel="me" on the link and a lot of
services do this for you already. That says,
"Hey this really is the same person." So if
you know me by my Twitter handle, and my Twitter
handle points to my blog and my blog points
to my Google page, etcetera, you can find
me by a bunch of those things. So, anybody
that already knows me by one of those services
can come and find me on this new place.
Google has something called the social graph
API where we've basically taken all of that
data and preprocessed it and served it up
by quick API so you don't actually even have
to do that crawling yourself, you can just
put it in any URL and get back the other "me"
URL's down the stream and use that to help
you find other people. The other thing you
can do is use webfinger again which advertises
a set of services based on an email address.
So, if you just know somebody by their email
address and you want to know more about them,
webfinger provides a way to do that. And then,
of course, most services have contact APIs
that let you pull out the friends you've already
made on an existing service, and use those
to find friends on a new service. Because
you don't necessarily want to have the same
exact friends everywhere you go, but you'd
at least like to know when somebody you've
already got a relationship with, also uses
the tool you do so you can decide if you want
to interact with them there as well. Like
I said before, one of the most exciting things
going on is that more and more of the mainstream
services are supporting these standards, are
supporting these capabilities and increasingly
doing so based on open standards. Uh, the
rel="me" thing that I mentioned is called
microformat, Portable Contacts is a standards
for accessing people data, and OpenSocial
also has standards people data information.
And of course protecting this are standards
like OAuth since often times your friends
list is not public information.
Now, people often say, you know, what if I
want to keep separate profiles and friends
and I mentioned this before, and what I want
to say here first before I jump into the demo,
that the notion you should just keep in your
mind is that on each site you are represented
by a list of identifies. This might be an
email address, but it might be a Twitter ID
or a Facebook ID or a URL to any other webpage
or a cell phone, anything that sort of uniquely
identifies you. And uh, I'm apparently running
on reserve battery power now, do we have a
cable, John, that you can plug in? Reserve
power failure, that would be a, I would cut
this slide a little bit short wouldn't I?
[pause]
Uhh, suspended so you can adjust the situation,
no I actually would want to keep talking.
Thank you Mac, alright, pause while I feed
the beast.
[pause]
Mmmmm, electrons. Alright, back to our regular
scheduled program. Okay, so think of yourself
as a list of identifiers and then as site
developers what you should do is let your
users attach as many of these identifiers
as they want and just let them control which
one of them you can use to find the person
by or not. So, I should be able to sign up
with an email address that I want to receive
notifications from you from, doesn't necessarily
mean I want everyone who knows that email
address to automatically be able to find me
there. And I think if you think about it that
way, then it's not as scary because you can
give users control over exactly how they're
found and you can let them be found in a lot
of different ways. And of course you can,
when you have those identifiers, and you pull
in contacts, you've matched them up against
each other, and you figure out who you know
on the site, you can decide to use that just
as a suggestion, as in, "Hey these are the
people you know" or in some cases it might
appropriate to even just automatically follow
them. For example on Plancast, I can automatically
follow the plans of all the people I’m following
on Twitter. And for them, you know, again
you can sort of make the business decision
based on what works best for your app, whether
that's appropriate or not. And same for when
I want to share data back out to other websites.
So, now if I know the other website you are
on, I can say, "Hey maybe you want to tweet
this out, or maybe you want to share this
on Buzz." And it just sort of works, you can
decide again how automatic or not it is based
on the site you use.
Let me show you a little plumbing demo for
that as well.... So, we'll leave XAuth behinds,
we'll leave Google behind. So, here's my Google
profile, and it's one of many profiles that
supports some of these standards. So, you
can see here that it's let me link to some
of the other profiles I use, and I haven't
linked to every profile I’ve used, just
the ones I think are, are important. And if
I go into the social graph API, and this is
just a little demo console, and I type in
that profile URL, you can see that it's found
a bunch of links to other websites. And one
of the things that cool is that it's not just
the websites I've linked directly from my
Google profiles, it's also the websites they
link to and so forth, and so it's sort of
the full set of public websites that I've
been comfortable sharing. And like I said,
Twitter does this, LinkIn, Digg; all these
sites support these really cool "me" things
so it's not something we have to be a geek
to set that up. A lot of your users already
have this information and you're just not
using it. So, now you actually can know me
by a whole bunch of different places and if
any of those people come, they can find me
as well. And then I mentioned webfinger, Chris
Messina went through a little more of the
code this morning, but basically it's a standard
way for service to provide a little more of
discovery information based on an email address.
And the way it works is basically you take
the domain off, look up the well known location
for webfinger based on the domain, and then
pass in the user name to find that user's
specific information. So, for example, if
I go and look up Joseph, jsmarr@gmail, let's
say you just know me by my email address.
Here's a sort of human readable-ish version
of what webfinger spits out and one of things
you'll notice here is it says, "Oh, Google
supports Portable Contacts and here's the
me endpoint for Portable Contacts, so here's
my profile and my friends." And if you go
hit that information, here's the output and
you can see it's sort of a machine readable
version of all the data that's on my profile.
So it's got my name, it's got my photo, it's
got the other sites I use, it's got, you know,
what other companies I went to, so all that
information you might have to make me fill
in from scratch, you can just use immediately,
because I’ve already published it publically,
and because there are these open standards,
it's actually ready for you to consume right
away. And lots of other sites do the same
thing. In fact, I should mention uh, I believe
we just launched the Buzz API if not, scoop,
I think we did though, and all the Buzz people
API's are all Portable Contacts as well. So
for example here, this is all the people I’m
following on Buzz, you can see here it says
@following. And this one is in JSON, the pervious
one's in XML, they both work in both formats
so you can use whatever you want, but what's
cool is that since in Buzz the people you
are following is public by default, you can
go and find a bunch of information about my
friends, and one of the things you'll notice,
a bunch of the URL's they've hooked up is
in that information and you can run those
through social graph API and you can see how,
very quickly this gives you quite a rich tapestry
of information to help get users up and running
and wired. So, it's very cool that this all
works and all works in a way that actually
none of this is Google specific, it's just
using these open standards. Okay, uh yeah.
Let's go back to the talk. Nope...So, hopefully
that made sense. Uh, some mechanical advice
for this. So, basically what I said is you
want to let users claim and verify as many
identifiers as appropriate. With an email
address you can send them an email and have
them click on it. Although increasingly you
can use webfinger and figure out if it supports
OpenID, and then just make them do OpenID
to collect the same information, right? So,
for anything like Google or Yahoo! or others,
they'll give you the email addresses as part
of the OpenID round trip so you can actually
use that with just a nice little lightweight
pop-up to verify their email address and it
can be a lot less friction for you then making
the user fish that confirmation email out
of that spam folder and to click and prove
they really own it. And then you can use the
rel="me" links to find even more site they
use and so forth. And you just want to make
sure users have control over how their findable
so that they don't feel like they are being
trapped by sharing that information with you.
And then you can use the OAuth that you got
before to look up their contact's API and
then essentially just do a merge of all the
identifiers of all their friends versus all
the identifiers on your site and boom, you've
got your list of local users. And you can
keep doing this as I said on an ongoing basis,
so as you make new friends both on your site
and other sites, you can constantly have that
information stay up to date.
And so back in our island world, once the
islanders figured out how to do this, life
was good because they could each live on their
islands and they still know how to find each
other and get in touch when they want to.
And there was much rejoicing. So, what could
we do to further help the islanders? Well,
I'm going to hand it back to my colleague
Dr. Panzer. I'm going to give you a little
hint, it involves some magic salmon and we
will be throwing salmon out later. Alright,
let's go find some more friends on Plaxo first.
>>John Panzer:
Awesome. Thank you Joseph and... [pause],
wonderful.
>>Joseph Smarr:
By the way we can almost take no credit for
the really beautiful graphics, that's all
Chris Messina.
>>John Panzer:
Yeah, I want to give props to Chris because
he's awesome.
>>John Panzer:
--He's a genius. Yes. He spent way too much
time on this, I hope it's obvious.
>>John Panzer:
Yeah, yeah. [audience laughter]. Okay so the
islanders figured out that they can send messages
to each other, the bottles are working out
kind of okay, but there are problems with
them. So, one issue that these islanders have
is they want, they want to find out what's
happening on their other islands. And when
they do this the technology that they have
is they go back to the other island. They
all go to the boat and see if there's new
messages waiting. And they check, and they
check, and they check, and often there is
nothing there. Actually, most the time there
is nothing there. Sometimes when there is
something there, they're not checking in so
it takes a while until she's going to come
back you know, she's mad. And that's a problem
because she's not getting her updates.
Problem number 2, these islanders are going
around, and they're doing complicated things.
They're taking rich photos and videos, and
they're doing sharing and they're doing all
kinds of stuff and they want to tell people
about it, but the language that they have,
the, the, amount of stuff that they put in
bottles isn't sufficient to the task. They
can only put little plain text in there and
the meaning gets squished out. So, that's
a problem for them. They want to keep everybody
up to date about all of their activities and
they want this to happen automatically. They
don't want to be writing messages while they
are out looking at whales. They want it to
happen just, as part of a natural course of
things. They want to know that all their buddies
on all the islands, they want to know that
they are looking at whales' right then. So,
so they have this rich content and they want
to give it to the right place. So, this is
a problem. The island geeks have a solution.
So, they came up with a series of technology
that solves these problems one by one. Now,
this was a problem on the islands and it's
also a problem here on our social web. So,
what problems do we have? We have problem
number one. The technology we have today for
retrieving data across the sites is basically
the RSS feeds and polling. So, you're polling
over and over again. This is a problem because
it means it's not scalable. But the first
problem is that the content that gets squeezed
in these RSS feeds, it gets turned basically
into text messages and a lot of the meaning
is lost. And different sites don't talk with
the same language to each other so things
get dropped on the floor, the meaning gets
squeezed out. Two, things are slow because
there's lots of wasting efforts polling, it's
not scalable and these things just take a
lot of time. You don't get in real time updates
when somebody's going to a party, you find
out two hours later and that's no good. And
three, when content does get where it's going,
and you actually have a conversation about
it, the conversation ends up only at being
silo'd at these other islands and the first
island, which created the party, never finds
out about it. So, the conversations get fragmented
and it's hard to keep track of what everyone
is saying. Okay? So, all this, yeah.
>>Joseph Smarr:
--What is it?
>>John Panzer:
Bad for users,
[audience mimics]
bad for developers, sad. But, good news!
[audience mimics], yes.
>>Joseph Smarr:
--That's a C minus participation right there.
>>John Panzer:
[laughs] You've got to do better. Alright,
so now you can share and consume real time
rich activity data across the web. You can
annotate existing feeds so that there's an
upgrade path that doesn't involve replacing
the entire universe by adding in additional
metadata, verbs and objects, there's a standard
for this called ActivityStrea.ms, Chris has
talked in detail about this, this morning.
I'm going to show a few examples coming up
and you get, this makes it much easier to
re-syndicate your content. Real time PubSubHubbub
has been deployed across the web now as many,
many, many places using it; and great success.
You can use existing public hubs or you can
roll your own, totally up to you, and the
net result is that the hub takes on all the
heavy lifting. If you are a publisher, you
just ping it, if you are a consumer, you just
get the data pushed to you; in real time.
And finally, uh, you can now make your users
replies and cross-site mentions "swim upstream"
to the source of the content or to the person
being mentioned. And so you can post replies
back to the original source with the commenter's
permission and mentions can get sent where
they really should go, which is to the person
whose is being mentioned. So I'm going to
do a quick demo...and...
>>Joseph Smarr:
--Your demo thing is linked, that's way more
sophisticated than what I did.
>>John Panzer:
The web…yes, okay…so there are some existing...well,
[chuckle]...
>>Joseph Smarr:
That's good.
>>John Panzer:
Yes, oh yes, win! So there are existing sites
which are actually implementing some of this
so I'm going to demo some of them today. Two
of them are Cliqset and statusnet so we're
going to give them a little bit.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Aren't you going to sign in with your existing
account?
>>John Panzer:
[sigh], yes.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Real time heckling.
>>John Panzer:
Yes, I'm going to sign in... Okay, great.
And now oh, so on Cliqset, it's just a microblogging
site, you can write messages in general and
you can also mention other people. So, let
me do a quick... I'm going to cheat and copy
and paste. Something, just a moment...
>>Joseph Smarr:
Just scroll over?
>>John Panzer:
Yeah, I'm going to scroll over here. Yes,
thank you very much for your technical assistance,
yeah. This copying pasting business? Way to
complicated…alright…alright. Here we go.
So, there we go, I’m on the site and, I
want to tell my friends, Jack Salmon wants
to tell his friends about this cool YouTube
video which I'm not going to play here but
if you guys want to go play you can. And he's
going to tell them about it and he's going
to mention them. And they're not on, they're
not actually on Cliqset, they're actually
on the island sites that they prefer. And
so I now have, I've posted this publically
so that everyone knows about it, but specifically,
I want Kate and John to know about this. So
uh, Kate is over on island status.net, which
is her own little site. And if I hover over
this, Cliqset has this nice little feature
where they’ve got a nice little hover card
of Kate and you can see, I can see her picture.
Now that picture, by the way, Cliqset doesn't
know a thing about this, that picture is retrieved
via webfinger from StatusNet automatically,
there's no pre-federation here, it's, it's
all automatic. Zero config. So, and there's
lots more information that could be displayed.
So, if I want to go over and see Kate, I go
over to Kate, and if I go over and look at,
they call, "replies." So, on Kate's site,
she sees the stream of replies and everyone
else can see it too in this case, and it's
showing the mention from across the web, and
as you can see it got pushed in automatically.
And I'll show you why that's safe and why
it can be spam free in a little bit. Okay,
the other, by the way, this is not just an
address, this also went off to a little demo
site...
>>Joseph Smarr:
[quietly] Yay!
[pause]
>>John Panzer:
[laughs] SO this is a problem with identity,
we have too many identities going on here.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Sorry about that.
>>John Panzer:
That's alright, I'll just blow your identity
away. Alright...that's fine.
[pause]
Come on...okay and this mention has shown
up, it's shown up twice since I've been demoing
this. It's now shown up in my mentions, over
here as well, so two places. So, we now have
three places that are interoperating and exchanging
these mentions automatically, which is great.
Now, I'm going to go back and explain how
this works and how you might build this. Okay,
so, a lot of this is going to be very familiar.
So, number one, implement webfinger. So, you
publish a /.well known/host-meta file to point
at per-user XRD's. Then for each per-user
XRD you put up a link that Joseph was showing
us, and this lets you bootstrap all these
different protocols. And that's why webfinger
is a good starting point. And finally you
use these email identifiers which technically
the machines know as A-C-C-T identifiers.
Or URLs, mostly these protocols, Salmon doesn't
care. All he cares that they're machine-readable
and that you can use webfinger with them.
Okay, so, the next thing that I'm going to
show you is a little bit more of how this
works under the hood with webfinger, I’m
just going to show the links. That right there...
So, how did I find Kate? This is the same
tool that we saw before. kate@eyeland.status.net.
and there's a whole bunch of metadata you
can get about Kate, that's public. Some of
its services that Kate uses, and some of it
are pieces of data that she wants to publish
for the world. One of them is this here, Salmon
replies. She wants to be told when people
are talking about her, so puts a link up.
And people post to that link when they post
a mentions to that link. If she doesn't want
mentions, she doesn't put the link. She also
publishes so that she can publish things out
to the web; she publishes a public key in
her webfinger. This is actually very powerful
and very generic. And in addition she's got
a lot of profile information, all of the things
that Joseph showed; I'm not going to go into
detail, but obviously you can get cool things
that pull the profile picture automatically
which is what users actually care about. So,
notice that the other thing she can, that
I'm going to show, I can very quick, you don't
have to show, have all the same information.
The nice thing about this is that it's generic
and you can publish as much or as little information
as you want. In this particular demo of this
little app engine I want to put up only has
two little tiny pieces of information. So,
you can be as public or as private as you
want to be. You've just got a few pieces of
information that are required to make protocols
work. But it's all very regular, it's links
and types and essentially that's it. So, I'm
going to go back... Alright and I’m going
to talk a little bit about the data that's
being sent back and forth. Because the data
that was being sent back and forth under the
hood about those mentions are actually activities,
you know I've mentioned you and here's the
text. So, the first thing you want to do is
add activity:verb and activity:object-type
into your feeds and you can use Cliqset if
you are consuming feeds. You can use that
as a proxy to infer a lot of this data. You
want to map to existing verbs where possible,
there's a standard for this so that people
can, when they're really talking about the
same things you can map to the same things.
If they're not really talking about the same
things you can extend it, you can add your
own. And the cool thing is you can augment
this so you can have a generic verb, you can
have a more specific one and people will actually
understand whichever one they can. And you
can also put up unstructured content as well
for compatibility meaning that you don't have
to boil the ocean to get started with this
you can get started as soon as today and it
will work, and it will work better when everyone
else starts implementing it too. And then
finally, when you are generating, when you
are creating something, you want to get credit
for it so include a generator which gives
you a attribution for this information. And
as also use webfinger.
Now when you are consuming activities, same
thing in reverse. You want to map the verbs
and the objects to your own data types. Provide
a good UI so if you've got a, if you're getting
this information, if you know somebody is
sharing a video with you, you can customize
a UI. They can customize the heck out of the
UI because you know that your friend shares
the video, it's not like an email which you've
got like 27 attachments and you don't know
what to do with it. So, you can share photos,
you can display the thumbnails, you can do
cool things with it. In the fallback, the
very worst case, you can always just play
the unstructured content which is likely going
to be fairly good because it's what the producer
wanted you to show. And then display the activity:generator
for attribution. And webfinger as always,
you can go off, if you can't find the data
you need, you can go and do webfinger discover
to get more data as we saw with Kate's profile
photo. Next, if you're doing feeds, you really
want to do PubSubHubbub because that will
make sure these things happen in real time.
And when that video gets shared out, all of
those people get to see it right away. And
for some videos, that's actually very important.
For things like party and events that's really,
really important. So, this is pretty standard
in that you add a link. You post a ping post
to your hub when you have updates. You can
either run your hub or use a public one, we've
got a public one at Google which everyone
can use. And when your subscribing to feeds,
look for the hub link, if it's there so that
means you can use it to subscribe and get
content pushed to you without you having to
do anything. So, this is almost, there's almost
no downside to this. So, you get things immediately
you do less work, you spend less money, and
you have a better user experience. So, next,
Salmon, which is one of the newer technologies
here, and by the way I'm going to, I'm happy
to kind of go over into more depth in and
question and answer session later I just want
to make sure we cover all these things at
a medium level. So, if you want to produce
Salmon, and produce a stream which Salmon
can swim up to. If you want Salmon comments,
if someone is commenting on something in your
stream and you want to know about it, and
you want to add it to your comments. So you
add a <link rel='salmon'>, there's a pattern
here, links are really, really useful. Point
to the Salmon endpoint you accept a POST,
you take the POST, you add a comment when
you see a Salmon that's valid and then you
do the same thing for mentions. Mentions are
really almost the same thing as comments except
that they're not a comment on something, they're
just a mention of somebody. So, you can check
to see if their mentioned on there and then
tell them about it or display it, whatever
makes sense for your use case. Okay so that's,
that's accepting Salmon from downstream, but
if you want to send Salmon, for example you
have something that does comments, so you
look for the link, you post to it, you-you're
going to sign the content before you send
it so you can get out, verify that it came
from the person, it's not just a spam bot
or something. And also if it's, depending
on your service, you need to make sure that
your users understand that their comments
are being broadcast potentially throughout
the web. Salmon is intended for public content
right now and they, users, should know that
their comment stream is being pushed upstream.
So that's fairly, at a high level, a very,
very simple, Salmon mentions are almost the
same thing except that you're doing discover
on the person that's being talked about. So,
anytime you see an identifier, which can be
something from somebody's address book, it
can be somebody typing in an actual email
address, in the body of the message with a
special character, whatever the UI is, and
you know that the writer is intending to call
attention, to call that person's attention
to the message, then you can look to see if
the recipient wants to know about it. And
if they do you post a Salmon.
So, here what I’m going to do next is show
an example of an activity, and how it gets
signed as a Salmon. Because you can sign anything,
with this protocol called Magic Signatures
that Salmon uses. And we'll see both at once.
Let's see here... Why am I signing in again?
[pause]
Okay great, so I just want to show a real
quickly here, this is an example of a generic
atom entry which is a valid, a hopefully valid
salmon. It's not letting, it's not accepting
the salmon right now because the author is
bogus. The author is your user ID here, which
does not match the person I'm logged in as.
So, I can't, this application is not letting
me sign in. If I actually go through and
[pause]
and I put my true user into it. Okay, great.
So, what this is doing is behind the scenes
it's dynamically checking, and its saying
is this person, does the author match the
person who's actually signed in. And it does,
so I'm saying, great, I’m vouching for,
and then signing it for me, it's turning it
into a Salmon. Which down here is a little
hard to see, but is a
[pause]
turns into a chunk of, basics farmcoded text
which isn't actually encrypted, it's just
signed. And there's a signature down here
at the bottom. And the key point of Salmon
in this form is that when you get one of these,
you check the signature and if it doesn't
match then you drop the Salmon immediately.
It means it's a bad fish, and you sniff it
and it's gone. If it passes then you can do
a bunch of other tests and see if that person
is the, is a legitimate person, or if he's
marked as a spammer, but at least you know
for certain that the person who is the author,
actually sent the thing. It's not like email
where you can just type whatever you want
in the from field. So, what you can do is
verify the signature and behind the scenes
is actually going through a public key verification
process and going off and doing webfinger
to retrieve that public key I showed you before
and checking it against the signature and
it's getting an A-OK. And then when you actually
want to look at the data, you can unfold this,
in this case in an atom. This also works for
JSON activity streams and it shows the data,
there's original author, you can look at everything,
it's been verified. And you can also carry
along the original signature when you want
to re-syndicate this back out and prove, and
keep the proof that the author signed it.
So, this helps combat spam and abuse in this
whole system which is one of the big problems
with a totally distributed system with no
central authority.
So, let me do one other quick demo. Actually
we're kind of running out of time here, but
activ- I won't go into showing the whole glory
of activity streams here, but it's an extension
of this where you are adding verbs and objects.
And if you've seen Chris' talk, he's gone
into a lot more detail on this structure.
But rest assured, this can sign activities
just as well as it can it can plain atom.
Alright...okay so, now the islanders, back
to our island story. They solved their problems,
they've got a series of tubes that are pubbing
and subbing and when they want to send messages
they just pop it in and they come, and it
goes immediately in real time to the, whoever
is subscribed to them. And that could have
gone through a hundred tubes to all the recipients.
Now with Salmon you can now reply and the
reply can go, the reply doesn't have to back
through the tubes, it can actually go to the
original source which can be in a number of
tubes back removed. And so she calls the magic
Salmon hands it the message, Salmon signs
it, and delivers it and the recipient knows
it's a good message because its Salmon protected,
it's salmonized. You can do the same thing
for mentions. So, if I'm just writing a message
and I want to tell people about that cool
video, I don't have to get out of my hammock.
I just write that message and I call my magic
Salmon and it splits it into two magic Salmon
and delivers it simultaneously to via HTP
posts to the recipients and they verify them
and they, they know the recipient sent it.
This means that, by the way, given that you
have social networks, you can use this for
access control because you can believe the
sender, that means you can check to see if
the person is really on my buddy list, and
therefore it's okay for them to send me messages
and wake me up in the middle of the night.
So, all of these technologies build on each
other. Alright? So, great the islanders have
solved their problems, they're happy, everything
is awesome and now everybody is having a great
party. Party time. Everybody lived happily
ever after. Now, here to wrap things up and
to summarize everything that we've learned
so far I'm going to hand it back over to Joseph.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Thanks John. That's pretty cool stuff right?
Every story needs a moral and so let's take
a moment to pause and reflect on the moral
of the story of these islanders here. They
had a problem visiting each other and trying
to go to new islands. And that's bad because
people should be able to live where they want
right? And with OpenID, they were able to
go where they wanted without all that friction.
But then once people were living in different
places, they really wanted to be able to still
stay in touch with each other, and find each
other, and get in touch. And with webfinger
they were able to do that as well. You shouldn't
have to only communicate with people, and
there's a reason we use the @ symbol here.
I mean email didn't used to have an @ symbol.
You used to only be able to email people on
the same server as you. And then they invented
the @ symbol so you could send email to other
computers. And we're essentially reinventing
that today with webfinger. And lastly they
wanted to not just get in touch with each
other, but actually send rich content in real
time. And so activity streams allowed them
to send photos and videos and locations and
all those stuff that people are really doing
today. And to share in real time, and to have
conversations that actually span these different
islands. And similarly, I should be able to
share with just as much fidelity, if you and
I are on different services, just like if
I'm on Gmail and you're on Yahoo! Mail, we
should be able to email back and forth including
rich attachments and HTML and so forth, and
the messages should show up with same speed
that they do within a closed service. There's
really no reason we can't solve these problems
and I hope you've seen we've actually made
a lot of progress. And I'll just sort of conclude
by saying that we've used this island metaphor
a lot, and you know this is an xkcd cartoon
from a few years ago, and what's interesting
to me is that it still more or less rings
true. We're still basically in these different
islands. And from Google's perspective, we
think it's great that there's lots of different
social websites out there. The web has tons
of different websites too, and what made the
web work was everybody could put their own
website and they could all link to each other
and so anybody that came along with a new
idea could just get involved and it could
take off and everybody was better. And that's
exactly what we want to see on the social
web. We want there to be a lots of different
cool social sites, niche social content, other
sites that have social features, and users
be able to play with them, choose the ones
they want, not have to start over from scratch
every time. And we are getting really far,
I mean, I can say we've been talking about
this for years it seems like, but each year
there's just an amazing progress going on
in terms of not only how much capability there
is, to actually have rich experiences across
sites, but how many big players are actually
getting involved and doing this, and how many
small players are coming up and using this
from day one. And increasingly how much is
based on open standards that you really can
just work with the standards and work with
anybody that supports them instead of having
to try and pick winners and losers today.
So I think that's really exciting and it's
got us really excited, and I hope you can
see now it's something you can actually jump
in and start playing with today. And so to
conclude, we've put a bunch of helpful links
if you want to learn more and play with things.
And of course we'll be around to answer questions
and send Salmons if you'd like. Thank you
very much and we'll open up to questions now.
[audience clapping]
So please come to the mic if you have a question,
I think there might also be some questions
on Google Wave, so feel free to shout those
out in between. Go ahead.
>>male questioner #1:
So, as someone's who's on the Salmon developer
list, I see all the connect comments and some
of the discussion and was really eager to
use Salmon. How long do you think it'll be
until we get to the point where there's just-
or where we are with OAuth, where's there's
a bunch of language libraries already out
there, to make it, so you don't have to really
understand the workings of the protocol very
intensely?
>>Joseph Smarr:
--Salmon!
>>John Panzer:
Everyone that asks a Salmon question, gets
a salmon. Thank you. Yes, so the-
>>Joseph Smarr:
--That works.
>>John Panzer:
I'm very optimistic, we're making good progress
. There are already Java, Python, and PHP
libraries available for Salmon and some people
are talking about Ruby. Which I think is an
awesome start. So it's gaining a lot of traction.
We have interop, as you saw, which is the
most important thing with this stuff and there
are services which have deployed, which are
using these libraries. And we're working to
collect them, put them up and have them be
an open source, in a central location. So,
I think that'll be very, very soon, and we
are planning to use these for our own deployments
for our production services at Google as well.
>>Joseph Smarr:
And all these building blocks, almost all
the libraries have come from developers who
got excited and wanted to contribute one.
So none of these specs are that hard so it'd
be great to jump in and if it's not in the
language of your choice or you don't like
the existing libraries, build a better one,
open source it, share it with the community,
and that's how we all grow. Great question.
Thanks. Next.
>>male questioner #1:
Thank You
>>male questioner #2:
Slight bit of background, I have a friend
of mine who came from a very abusive family,
so privacy for her is a very touchy subject.
Similarly, there's a lot of applications that
want to ask for access to the contacts, so
you know, they say can I have access to the
Google contacts and I didn't hear anything
in the protocol that allowed me as a user,
and also me as an app developer too, because
I would like to ask for a number of things
and then if the user goes over to Google to
authenticate themselves, for Google to be
able to, as part of the protocol specification
with that, they would be able to unselect
options. For example, say that Amplifeed,
my product, can access the contacts but only
these 25 contacts, in only this once. And
I would like to be able to support that as
a way to reduce the friction, because if I
ask for more than what they're comfortable
for they just go away
>>Joseph Smarr:
Right.
>>male questioner #2:
as opposed to just giving a generated experience.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Yep.
>>male questioner #2:
But I haven't heard anything about that that
would allow Google to enforce it because obviously
I as the developer can kind of bandage it
myself but I'm not to be trusted because
>>Joseph Smarr:
Right.
>>male questioner #2:
I have incentive to lie.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Yep, very good question. Here you get a salmon
even though it's not a Salmon question. Look
you are not going to bring a bunch of salmon
to stage and not going to throw them alright?
If anybody wants one just put your hand up.
So, yes very good questions, so actually you
can do what you are talking about, it's not
something that is, the policy isn't really
baked into the specs but the specs allow for
it. So when you are making an OAuth request,
you basically are passing in the scopes that
you want that token to be for. And there's
nothing that says how fine or coarsely grained
the scopes can be. So, it's up to services
that allow you to specify that level of granularity
in those scopes. But different services can
take different ideas. So, for example, I know
Microsoft's services tend to have a lot more
of that fine grained. Is it just for an hour,
is it for the whole time, is it just one folder,
is it all folders? And the OAuth token they
give back it just encodes what scopes were
granted in that token and then when you use
that token you just can't fetch anything that's
not in those scopes. And so at that point
it really becomes a choices of the provider,
and there is a trade-off. If you make the
consent UI too complicated, you often have
greater drop-off just from user confusion.
But as you say if you make it too rigid, and
the user is not happy with the offer, then
they can drop off that way too. So there's
kind of some fine-tuning that can go on and
that's really an opportunity for services
to compete and differentiate each other based
on that level of customizability versus kind
of a quick thing you can up and running with.
But the specs actually support all of that
very flexiblly. And I think your use cases
are very good ones that people are going to
have to figure out how to do in general. All
of these things need to get more refined over
time.
>>male questioner #2:
But it didn't sound like, it sounds like it's
up to each individual OAuth provider.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Right, in terms of exactly how fine a grain
scope they are and what they return.
>>male questioner #2:
Oh, okay.
>>Joseph Smarr:
And one could imagine if a bunch of sites
want to offer similar types of primatives,
you could imagine those getting standardized
too, there's nothing that prevents that. That's
just still early days for a lot of that. Now
I know there was a Wave, so if anybody has
their computer open, and there are questions
in there that you think are worth asking,
please ask them on their behalf as well. Or
come up to the mic.
>>female questioner #1:
Hi.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Hello!
>>female questioner #1:
So, in relation to that question, I may have
just missed it, but I didn't hear where Google
lets their users use Google Gmail as a login
without giving away their contacts. Is that
something Google does?
>>Joseph Smarr:
Yes, yes.
>>female questioner #1:
--How?
>>Joseph Smarr:
You have to ask for each individual piece
you want and so you can just login and say
I'm going to be anonymous, or I'll just give
you my name but not my address book, or I'll
just give you my calendar, it's fully customizable.
>>female questioner #1:
I didn't see that.
>>Joseph Smarr:
--Yeah, in that demo I just did, I did everything
to kind of just make the point.
>>female questioner #1:
--Okay.
>>Joseph Smarr:
But yes, you have complete control over what
you give out.
>>female questioner #1:
Okay.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Yep, good question. She ran away before she
got a salmon, they're getting smarter.
>>John Panzer:
Yeah.
[laughs]
>>Joseph Smarr:
You alright?
>>female questioner #1:
I thought you were out!
>>Joseph Smarr:
Never! No.
[salmon being thrown by John]
>>female questioner #1:
Ahhh! No.
>>John Panzer:
Whoops, whoops.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Any other questions? Any moderator questions?
You now know everything about distributed
social networking?
>>male questioner #3:
What do you do when a Salmon endpoint is down
temporarily?
>>Joseph Smarr:
Good, what do you do when a Salmon endpoint
is down temporarily?
>>John Panzer:
Good question, we're...should I throw it?
[salmon thrown] [laughs] So if you're uh,
the question is where the Salmon you want
to post it to? Is that one down temporarily?
>>male questioner #3:
Yeah.
>>John Panzer:
So, you can queue. Same as I'm sure you have
for other services. Or you can tell the user
sorry we can't, we couldn't deliver your Salmon,
and it didn't work. So that's a quality service
that. If things like the webfinger protocol,
endpoints aren't available, then you have
to make some decisions about what to do next.
You may not be able to access the user, maybe
they don't exist, you can't really tell. So,
a lot of this information is cacheable though.
So the host-meta, the webfinger, all that
stuff, you can set the cache headers on that
stuff so that you can, for whatever meets
your needs. And so you can ride out a lot
of service interruptions that way.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Okay so we have time for maybe one more question,
one more salmon. Did you guys catch that the
endpoint was salmon slap, I think that's awesome.
[John laughs]
Go ahead.
>>male questioner #4:
Have you talked something about groups? I
want to publish something about Salmon to
a group-
>>Joseph Smarr:
--Groups, mhmm.
>>male questioner #4:
-of people?
>>John Panzer:
So the question is you want to publish a Salmon
to a group?
>>male questioner #4:
Yeah.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Or share with a group,
>>John Panzer:
--Ah, share with a group, right. So I don't
think that anyone has gone into very great
detail on this but a little bit of thing is
that your groups are first class citizens
on the web, in a way, and they should be able
to have webfinger ID's which is perfectly
reasonable. Then when you mention them, or
you share to them, or send to them, you can
do group-like things with them. The difference
is from an email address, is that all you
can do with an email address, you can just
shove things to it. With a group, you can
discover things about it, like for example,
how to join the group without spamming people.
>>Joseph Smarr:
This also works with Portable Contacts so
in, if I give you my contacts I can say what
groups are part of in the Portable Contacts
data so maybe my family or my friends, or
my business. And then when you prove who you
are, we can check and actually see are you
in the family group. So, you can set policies
that say only let people share this with me
if people they're in the family or only share
it out to people who I've tagged as family
on a different network. Things like that,
so it's pretty good to compose. Salmon for
you. Yes sir.
>>male questioner #5:
Another question is for a use case for Salmon,
one thing that you mentioned is basically
collecting all the comments that you make
on the web, trying to, keeping ownership of
that repository of comments that you make.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Yep.
>>male questioner #5:
Could you explain how you would go about doing
that?
>>John Panzer:
Yeah.
>>Joseph Smarr:
You want to take that one?
>>John Panzer:
Okay, sure. So this has been talked about
a little bit, it hasn't been fully spec’d
out, but the idea is that you have the same
sort of endpoint that you do for mentions.
So, instead of someone mentioning you, you’re
doing, you’re having activity on the web
and it gets posted back to you at whatever
endpoint you've published in your webfinger
information. And it's signed so it's, it's
spam resistant. And that way it doesn't matter
what site you are on, you can get a carbon
copy of all your activities. And you can store
it, you can just store it on your hard drive
if you want to. Which is kind of cool and
useful because you have searchability and
history of what you are doing.
>>Joseph Smarr:
Yeah, you could think of the author of the
comment as sort of automatically mentioning
themselves right?
>>male questioner #5:
Right...
>>Joseph Smarr:
And actually if you login with your OpenID,
your endpoint is discoverable, that can just
work automatically. So, I've logged in with
my OpenID, you know who I am, you know my
public key, and every time I comment you can
post back to that. So it's actually a very
powerful combination.
>>male questioner #5:
So it's really depends on each, the service
that you use, them doing that for you.
>>John Panzer:
They
>>Joseph Smarr:
--Right.
>>John Panzer:
They're the ones actually generating the content,
>>male questioner #5:
--Right.
>>John Panzer:
The activities,
>>Joseph Smarr:
--Right.
>>John Panzer:
On your behalf and so they have to be kind
of the ones to submit it for signing...
>>Joseph Smarr:
--Although, there have been people, you know,
lots of sites run, things like discussed or
intensedebate, you can imagine if they added
it would work for lots of sites. There are
even browser plugins and a number of co-comment
and these things that would actually see when
you are posting a comment and they would grab
it and send it back up. So, maybe there are
things like that that will get you that, before
even people have done it all themselves.
>>John Panzer:
Yeah, and following "me links" can also help
you find this, these end points
>>Joseph Smarr:
All right folks we are out of time, we are
out of salmon, and thank you very much for
your time and I hope that was helpful
>>John Panzer:
--One more salmon.
>>Joseph Smarr:
and we'll be around.
[audience clapping]
Male #6:
John!